I like to start by giving everybody a
form of prayer. May God's peace and
blessings be upon every single one of
you.
And welcome to tonight's discussion, and
I think it's a very important topic.
It's an important topic between
believers, atheists, skeptics,
and those in between.
The discussion tonight will examine
whether the belief in evolution
disproves
the existence of a creator,
and how Darwin's theory of evolution is
utilized, understood, and conveyed in
contemporary society.
The structure is going to be very
simple. We're going to have
approximately 20 minutes each from each
of the speakers. Then there will be a
discussion between the speakers,
followed by a question and answer
session.
Everyone is mature.
Everyone is polite. Everyone is
tolerant. Everyone is compassionate.
Everyone is a decent human being. We've
all evolved to become Get the joke? No?
All right. So, basically,
let me introduce our respected speakers.
We have on my right, Professor
Jeremy Pritchard. He's an active
biologist and a senior lecturer in the
School of Biosciences at the University
of Birmingham.
His research career started in Wales and
currently he focus focuses on aphids in
Birmingham with stops in the USA, New
Zealand, and Europe.
He has published in many prominent
journals, including the Journal of
Experimental Biology, Global Change
Biology, and Biotechnology Letters.
His expertise is in how plants grow and
are affected by changes in environment,
the stress, including insect pests.
His expertise is also in evolution and
creationism, and he teaches and in
teaching and learning strategies at the
school and university. He's a
card-carrying
Darwinist. I don't know what that means,
maybe we'll find out today. And is
involved in teaching evolution at all
levels from primary school to
University of the Third Age.
Please give him a warm welcome.
Also to my right, we have Suboor Ahmed.
He is a well-known public speaker and
writer who has debated prominent
academics on philosophy and science. He
is currently pursuing post-graduate
studies in philosophy and has a
particular interest in the philosophy of
biology and is specializing in this
field. He is also the co-author of a
forthcoming book called Failed
Hypothesis: Essays on the Philosophy of
Science, Atheism, Consciousness,
Darwinism, and Islam.
So,
I don't know who's going first. I do
apologize. Professor? Professor, if you
don't mind, please, the audience. Thank
you. Thank you.
Okay. So, uh nice to be here. Um nice to
talk to you about this. The question
wasn't quite as specific as you just
heard there. It was, as opposed to me,
was uh
does evolution undermine God?
And um
in my philosophy, no, it doesn't.
So,
you know,
we can all go home.
Now, um
I have beliefs and not beliefs, and I
have a a view of the world. Um uh but I
thought what would be useful is to
briefly, if we're talking about the
relationship between religion and
science, I thought it would be useful to
briefly give an overview of how I see
science as coming to where it is now
from, say, the ancient Greeks. Okay?
Because I think unpicking and and
understanding where we are now and how
we look back helps us understand that
the type of question that you're posing
uh tonight.
So, Darwin's great insight
from my view is that he provides us with
the so-called tree of life.
He provides us with a coherent view of
how organisms are related, how they've
changed through time, and importantly,
and people often overlook this, how all
organisms are equal
at the for ends of the branches of these
trees of this tree.
Before Darwin,
people tended to think about the
organizing the world, the living world,
and then the inanimate world
as a hierarchy with some things higher
than others and
and better than others.
Darwin's theory, Darwin's ideas that we
largely accept today,
um are a mechanism of biological change.
Over the history of how we came to the
position that that that that we accept
largely today,
um
the history of this is not the history
of how the mechanism developed, but the
the ideas that Darwin had,
but whether change had happened at all
biologically or even in the geological
world.
What I'm going to argue is, in fact,
that the development of those ideas of
change
was dangerous to society. And that to
some extent that was encapsulated in the
in the relationship and the developing
relationship and to some extent the
existing relationship between science
and religion, science and God.
So, the Greeks, for example, would look
at the world and see the world like we
do, organisms all around them.
They would see stones, beetles, worms,
people,
maybe even the gods.
And they would organize them. They would
see that there was Some things were
simple, some things were complicated,
and they would organize them into a
hierarchy like a ladder.
With simple things at the bottom and
complicated things at the top.
Important thing about this ladder is
that it's static. You can't move up it.
Okay? So, it's it's not like a escalator
at New Street Station, although they're
often static these days as you may well
well know if you take the train through
New Street.
However, the important thing about this
is this disconnected
the living world. It was what we've
referred to as the the the Greeks
referred to as the great chain of being.
And it gives us an organization. It
means that things are not random, but it
gives us some
things that we carry through today often
in error, for example, that complex
things are better, which isn't
necessarily true. And it gives us this
idea of progress that we should strive
to move upwards even though this
this ladder does not move. So, there's
some concepts there that are
subsequently picked up in particularly
in Western
medieval society.
And um in Western society at that time
in the medieval time, um
it was a feudal society, and you had all
the money, all the power at the top of
that hierarchy with the slaves, the
serfs, workers at the bottom with very
little money. It's in the interests of a
society like that that nothing changes.
Because if things change, the people in
power lose some of that power, that
influence.
And this, you can argue, is encapsulated
in
in the Bible story, in the creation
story in Christian uh thought, uh in
which the world is created in 6 days and
then remains like that uh subsequently.
Things are constant. Things do not
change.
Uh things are always up as they have
been. And to the people at the bottom of
the pile, you will receive your reward
in heaven.
So, change is dangerous.
And if you want some evidence that that
that is the case, of course at the this
time, uh
it was the burgeoning of the of the the
Islamic science golden age.
And there were people
working like uh philosopher al-Biruni,
uh working on lots of things, very
famous. In fact, he's got a crater named
after him on the moon, dark side of the
moon, so you have to go around the moon
in a spacecraft to see it.
But he was thinking about lots of
things, including simple things, what we
might recognize as simple, that rivers
erode valleys and carry the silt down
the mountain and deposit it in a delta
at the bottom.
Rivers change the environment gradually,
very simple idea.
And through a convoluted series of uh
uh
because of the library at Alexandria
burning down and the the the the Moors
and the Christians in in southern Spain
and libraries in Granada and so on,
these ideas came to be picked up in the
West and developed. And they they've
been picked up, they've been used from
the Greeks through al-Biruni back to the
West.
And these were picked up in the 1200s by
the Pope. And these were recognized as
dangerous ideas because they were ideas
about change. Very simple, we might
think, and they were banned because the
logical conclusion of that, if you
follow it through, is changes happened
and that what it says in the Bible is
not in fact true.
So, ideas of change are dangerous. Uh
In in the West at that time, there there
was
people studied nature, but they didn't
study na- and it's the basis of modern
science. What we would they refer to as
natural theology, that we study the
living world to study the creation and
therefore get to know God better.
And in this, we have people like
Linnaeus, philos- um scientists like
Linnaeus,
who give us
the definition of a species. They look
at the world and they see that there are
some some things that are pigeons, there
are some things that are eagles, there
are some things that are donkeys, and
they're they're different, they're
definable,
and they're always the same. And we can
say we can therefore give it a Latin
name, Homo sapiens, whatever, because we
can define that thing and it remains the
same.
So, he gives us this idea that species
are fixed and he gives us clear species
descriptions. So, it well defines that
that world.
Uh and that is the framework into which
um natural theology, the study of the
natural world, uh comes along.
Indeed, uh
it gives us even
uh the the the idea of um that we can um
the natural theology can can be used to
almost argue for the existence of God.
So, the idea of the watchmaker uh
argument, that if we look at a watch, we
would deduce that a watchmaker had
designed it because of its complexity
and its function.
And we have we can have the same the the
natural theologian would argue the same
about observing something complex like
an eye that has clearly been apparently
designed in order to see in a complex
way and the designer therefore is God.
So intelligent design
was one of the consequences of that.
But we're not
there at the moment. Now things have
changed in in the way that we view the
world
and in a sense the seeds of that change
was sowed in a way by Linnaeus because
by describing species
very clearly
people started to be able to see that
the world wasn't random but that there
were if you looked at these species and
organized them some species were more
similar to each other than others.
So the eagle is more similar than it is
to to to to the pigeon than it is to the
donkey.
And so there an organization starts to
emerge.
And so what people started to say, well,
why are some things more similar to each
other than others?
And one of the answers
was
descent with modification from a common
ancestor. So there was a common ancestor
and then there were changes to this
ancestor, there was a split, there were
now two species and so on down and
so that diversity comes from descent
with modification from a common
ancestor. There was not
a a
a mechanism for that necessarily. It was
just a description of a a potential
phenomena.
Another things happened, Galileo removes
the world from the center of the perfect
universe, the perfect spheres.
The microscope sees new worlds in drops
of water.
Voyages of discovery to the other side
of the world see bi- see organisms,
animals not mentioned in the Bible
and so on.
And within society Uh, started
particularly in Birmingham with the
Lunar Society. We started to get ideas
about changing society. The Lunar
Society, a group of people used to meet
in Birmingham, discuss ideas, ideas
about changing machinery, ideas about
changing society. Uh, anti-slavery
campaigners, for example,
uh, in the Lunar Society, which ties
into Darwin's ideas about equality of
organisms. Direct, uh, links there.
But these ideas, again, were still seen
as dangerous. So, the Lunar Society, for
example, some of the Lunar Society,
their houses were attacked by mobs and
they were burnt down in Handsworth, uh,
because they were thinking about change
and people, particularly in England, saw
change as dangerous because in France
there was revolution going on, one of
the most serious sorts of, uh, of
change. Change is dangerous.
So, at this point we we had then a world
in which
either the world had been created and
then things like volcanoes and
earthquakes happened, cat- catastrophes.
And so the world was pop- created, but
then pockmarked by these catastrophes.
People could see volcanoes, people could
see earthquakes.
But then people were also picking up
those ideas about gradual change, the
things sort of things that Al-Biruni had
talked about, uh, that gradual change
happened and we had a phenomena called
uniformitarianism.
In that the world that we see about it
with the processes that operate in the
world, in both the geological and
potentially the biological world, are
the same processes that have always
operated. There is a consistency, there
isn't this big bang and it's changing
and we wait for the next earthquake.
Things change gradually, uh,
over time.
So, on the
I'm obviously skating very quickly over
this, but once that change, particularly
in the biological world, has been
established as a fact,
then you have to think as a scientist
about, well, how do we How does that
work? We describe something and What's
the mechanism by which which that change
occurs?
And there are lots of suggestions about
this.
Uh and Darwin himself comes up with the
theory that we now uh use as the
baseline today. And it's very simple. Uh
Darwin noted that more individuals were
produced by most organisms than can
possibly survive. And so there's a lot
of them die.
He noted that individuals are different
from each other. The individuals vary.
Uh and he also noted that um those
variations are inherited.
The key thing is that he suggested that
the possession of a certain variation
might allow you to survive rather than
another one.
So, the chance of survival of those
overproduced individuals is not a random
process. It's a process, if you like, in
inverted commas, of selection. Some of
them are selected by the environment to
survive and some aren't. So, if it was
cold and you had a set of organisms,
some who randomly had furry coats and
some of them who didn't,
the ones with furry coats would survive
because they can keep warmer. Their
survival is not random. They just
survive because they can keep warm
because randomly they have a have a
coat.
So,
at the time Darwin was writing,
the Victorians viewed the world
as a, if you like, one view of it as a
pastoral idyll. It was a beautiful
place. Nature was lovely. Uh we had
lambs gambling in the field trees. We
had uh grass and waterfalls, birds
singing.
Beautiful place to be.
A lot of the reaction to
these
mechanistic ideas about biological
change
come from a reaction against that. How
can beauty
be created by death and destruction?
And so, this is why,
uh, you may be familiar you might be
familiar with the phrase, but if not the
poem, but the phrase nature red in tooth
and claw by Tennyson.
And it's essentially
a
diatribe, uh,
that's probably too strong a word, but a
a cry of, um, despair from a man who
feels that his religion has been taken
away, that God has been taken out of the
equation uh, because God has now been
separated from the from the physical
world.
And it's interesting actually, and I
didn't realize this until quite late,
because I thought Tennyson's poem and
his cry reflected this debate that was
going on in society at the time. I
thought it was post-Darwin's
publication, but Darwin published in
1859, but that poem by Tennyson was
published in 1842.
So, it wasn't just Darwin who came up
with this These ideas had been
developing and were current in people's
thoughts, uh, for a while.
So,
I think
that the idea I think what just in that
brief overview, and obviously it's loads
of information. I think my colleague
probably knows a lot more about it than
I do. But, I think it's interesting to
see how we move from
or the development of science comes out
of that natural theology, that religious
view of the world. And that there's a
separation there,
uh,
potentially. Depends on how you want to
live your life, what your philosophy is.
Uh
and I think
people like Thomas Aquinas, the
Christian uh philosopher, actually
articulated that quite well.
That
you can only come to know your God by a
revelation.
Whereas the nat- you can't come to to
understand that through uh observation
of the natural world. These two things
uh were separated.
And I have Christian friends that I
speak to about this, and that is their
view. That is their view of their world.
That they study evolution, they're
comfortable with it, the processes that
we may talk about later. Uh but their
their their religion is a personal
internal thing uh and their God is is
not physically in the world like that.
Not my
Not my words, the words of other people.
Anyway,
I hope that is
an interesting overview of where I see
some of these ideas come from.
Um interested in people's thoughts in
the the follow-up. Thank you for
listening.
I'm going to start as Muslims do.
As-salamu alaykum. Peace be upon you.
First, I'd like to thank Professor
Jeremy Pritchard for taking part of this
dialogue. And also, the Prophet
Muhammad, peace be upon him, said,
"Whoever doesn't thank the people does
not thank God." So, alongside him, the
Birmingham ISOC, and also Beacons of
Sanctity, and all of you tonight for
attending.
So, we start in the name of God, the
Lord of mercy, the giver of mercy.
So, I'm going to pretty much, of course,
I'm going to agree with Professor uh
Jeremy Pritchard here that Darwinian
evolution does not undermine God, but
maybe for different reasons, which we
can discuss. Now, my my case is the
following.
Darwinian evolution does not undermine
God. Evolutionary biology works in a
neutral framework, in a metaphysically
neutral framework. What does that mean?
That means they are dealing with
real-life problems which impact every
single person in this room and every
single person in the world, which is
antibiotic resistance. They are not
involved in trying to spread atheism.
They're trying to stop the spread of
bacteria. Uh humbler, not humbler,
greater goals.
And to When we actually speak about
evolution, what are we actually
referring to? Because evolution can mean
many different things in many different
contexts. So, we're actually speaking
about Darwinian evolution, which is the
twin claim that all of life, bacteria,
human beings, leopards, Lady Gaga,
everything going back goes back to a
single common ancestor.
Alongside that, how did this change
happen? How do we get How do we get from
bacteria to elephants? How do we How do
we have a link between philosophers and
primates? It's actually through the
mechanism of natural selection. Now, I'm
just going to be uh frank about my
position. I believe Darwinian evolution
to be a valid scientific model, theory,
and paradigm. I do not believe
intelligent design or creation science
or anything like that is a valid
scientific theory. Now, that's what this
debate is uh what this debate is
actually about is about the PR problem
that is associated with Darwinian
evolution.
Now, the problem is there is a
difference between the public
understanding, which some of us have,
and the academic understanding.
Now, the public understanding, this
looks like a pretty much atheistic
theory.
For example, in the very popular book
Sapiens, written by the atheist
biologist Yuval Noah Harari,
this is what he says. There are no gods
in the universe, no nations, no money,
no human rights, no laws, and no justice
outside the common imagination of human
beings.
Now, that is a statement written in a
science book by a scientist, but clearly
that's not a scientific statement. Or
take the late evolutionary biologist and
atheist philosopher Julian Huxley, not
to be confused not to be confused with
T.H. Huxley, but he was his grandson.
This is what he wrote in his book
Religion without Revelation. This was
published in 1927, a long time ago.
But
this particular statement, I believe, is
very important for reasons which we
might mention later on.
It will soon be impossible for an
intelligent, educated man or woman
to believe in a god as it is now to
believe that the earth is flat. So
again, we have a evolutionary biologist
writing for the public, and the
statement obviously is not a scientific
statement.
And take the most popular atheist
manual, if you like, or book that we
have in the world, The God Delusion. The
central argument of The God Delusion is
based upon Darwinian evolution. And
Richard Dawkins is a great writer and
one of his most I I think it's his best
work, The Blind Watchmaker, which is
actually what made him famous. He
actually has this statement.
Darwin made it possible to be an
intellectually satisfied atheist. Now
again, this is a book about science
written by a scientist from Oxford, but
it is not exactly a scientific
statement.
And why this is important is because
this is the view that I'm going to be
challenging today. I do not think this
is a view which is even shared by
Darwin, because Darwin was never an
intellectually satisfied atheist. In
fact, Darwin said, "It seems to me
absurd to doubt that a man may be an
ardent theist and an evolutionist." Now,
Darwin had a very complex sort of
relationship with God, and we need to
take into account the words of John
Hedley from Oxford University, a
professor of science and religion there.
We should be careful about pigeonholing
a man who wouldn't pigeonhole pigeons.
So, I'm just going to be pigeonholing
him for sake of brevity, but we can go
into details about why he went through
those transitional changes later. He
first off started off as a Christian.
Now, as a Christian, he actually wanted
to at one point, as Professor Pritchard
knows or he may have briefly spoken
about, he actually wanted to become a
priest.
Later on, he became a deist. Now, what
is a deist? A deist is somebody who
believes in God but does not believe in
religion. He just believes in God.
Later on in life, he became an agnostic
because of the problem of evil. So,
nothing to do with science.
What's really interesting is Darwin
actually said, "In my most extreme
fluctuations, I have never been an
atheist in the sense of denying the
existence of God." In fact, this is a
very interesting incident. When a
reviewer wrote a review about Darwin's
book Origin of Species, and he said,
"This conception that the creator makes
the initial creation, which then evolves
naturally into all the forms of life
that we have today, is just as noble of
a thing for God to do
as for God to create every species
individually." Darwin was so impressed
by these words, he actually included it
in his second edition of The Origin of
Species. So, clearly, he was not an
intellectually satisfied atheist, and I
don't think he would agree with this
sort of taking his theory and making it
into an atheistic type of theory. In
fact, he explicitly wrote, "And this is
in a book a a very important book, I
think, written by Nick Spencer, Darwin
and God. Darwin particularly wrote, 'I
had no intention of writing
atheistically.'" Now, I believe Darwin
is correct and the popularizers, like
Richard Dawkins and Julian Huxley and
others, are incorrect in regards to
theology in terms of undermining
evolution uh undermining the existence
of God because of the conflation of two
types of naturalism. There is
methodological naturalism and
philosophical naturalism. Now,
methodological naturalism is very very
simple. We're all scientists. We walk
into this uh science room and we all
have a working assumption. Whenever we
look at nature, we're going to use
natural effects being explained by
natural causes. Very simple thing. So,
we're not going to refer to an an
immaterial mind, the soul, God, anything
like that. The second type of naturalism
is philosophical naturalism, which is
outside of this room as a belief system,
we only believe that nature exists and
there is no God, there is no soul, there
is no objective morals, or anything like
that. Obviously, these are two different
things. One is a working assumption in
science, and two, philosophical
naturalism is actually a belief. Now,
methodological naturalism is actually
very controversial. Well, it's not
controversial. It's been made to appear
controversial, but this is the very
reason why I mentioned earlier that I do
not believe intelligent design as a
theory to be science because it's not in
line with methodological naturalism.
Now, what Elliott Sober, an atheist
prominent philosopher of biology, what
he explains about this particular
conflation is this.
Evolutionary theory is neutral in
regards to the second definition of
naturalism, which is philosophical
naturalism. It only adopts the first.
He also has a very important um
statement about this. The theory of
evolution does not
does not rule out deism, the thesis that
God starts the universe in motion and
forever after declines to intervene.
But the theory does not also rule out a
more active God whose intervention into
nature fly under the radar of
evolutionary biology.
So this is very important to understand
what whenever a scientist is working
within his field a reference to God or
anything metaphysical is something that
they obviously cannot do.
And Scott Todd has he's another
evolutionary biologist and he explains
this and I think in a bit more clearer
terms.
Even if all the data points to an
intelligent designer, such a hypothesis
is is excluded from science because it
is not naturalistic. So that's
methodological naturalism. Of course,
the scientist as an individual is free
to embrace a reality that transcends
naturalism. So just to give you a brief
example, Darwin was against slavery.
He actually hated slavery. He he
considered it one of the great evils.
Now obviously, that is not something
which is based on science. That is his
philosophy. That is, you know,
a view that he holds that's nothing to
do with methodological naturalism
because from a methodological naturalism
point of view, evolution has made us be
moral
purely as a collective fiction to help
us survive. Now obviously, you can have
moral views outside of holding
methodological naturalistic views. Now
the idea that evolution undermines God,
that's obviously been cleared. But what
I want to do in my last couple of
minutes is focus upon
I think a more important question, which
is does evolution undermine the
Abrahamic God? Cuz obviously, as we
mentioned earlier, it doesn't undermine
the deistic concept of God. It doesn't
undermine the theistic concept of God.
but does it undermine the Abrahamic
conception of God? And the answer is
very simple, yes and no.
It's yes if somebody has a
misunderstanding about what science can
achieve. And if somebody thinks that
science gives us absolute results which
do not change. No, if they have an
academic understanding of science, if
they actually understand the philosophy
of science, which is that science gives
us working models about the world which
are then replaced by other models, and
science has a working assumption of
methodological naturalism, and it also
has many other multiple assumptions in
the theories they actually proposes.
This is explained well in uh Philosophy
of Science A New Introduction by Oxford
University. This is all mainstream stuff
by the philosopher Gillian Barker and
Philip Kitcher.
Science is revisable, hence to talk of
scientific proof is dangerous because
the term fosters the idea of conclusions
that are graven in stone. So, whether
you I'm going to use some complicated
language, I can explain a bit later,
whether you hold the view of scientific
realism or what's known as scientific
anti-realism, both camps, and this is a
pretty much consensus in the philosophy
of science that science doesn't give you
absolute results which are written in
stone.
Theories can be revised, theories can be
changed, and if you look at the history
of science, if we look at chemistry,
physics, and biology, we have this
constant evolution, we have this
constant change like the professor was
highlighting. This is even highlighted
by uh the uh Oxford professor Richard
Dawkins in his book A Devil's Chaplain.
We must acknowledge the possibility that
new facts may come to light which will
force our successors of the 21st century
to abandon Darwinism or modify it beyond
recognition. Now, that's the first time
I mentioned the word Darwinism, so
if you we we need to separate out some
things. Evolution simply means
biological change over time.
And
Darwin proposed the idea of universal
common ancestry along with natural
selection being the main driving force.
But as the professor pointed out, the
idea of common ancestry or universal
common ancestry was known before Darwin.
In fact, Professor Monier Williams from
Oxford University, a professor of
Sanskrit at the time of Darwin, he
actually said the ancient Hindus were
Darwinists 3,000 years before Darwin.
So, the idea of universal common
ancestry goes back obviously before, but
Darwin proposed the actual mechanism,
which is sometimes referred to as
Darwinism, sometimes referred to as
neo-Darwinism.
So, we should not neglect the philosophy
of biology and the philosophy of science
when we are trying to understand these
issues. So, Darwinian evolution does not
undermine theism, deism, or even the
Abrahamic God. You can be somebody who
believes and I actually know of Muslims
who are working within the field of
evolutionary biology. They're working
with the Quranic paradigm, which is that
if you save a life, you save the lives
of all.
When evolutionary biologists are working
across the world, they're trying to save
lives. They're not involved in these
sort of theological disputes. So, you
can say yes, common ancestry in some
aspects in terms of the tree of life,
not all obviously, but in some aspects
may conflict with my personal but I can
accept it as a valid scientific model
and contribute to this field. Now,
Darwinian evolution, according to a
mainstream understanding of the
philosophy of biology, is a framework
which is based on a probabilistic
framework which has assumptions and they
are valid disputes at conceptual and a
scientific level. Now, philosopher of
sci- philosopher of biology, sorry,
Elliott Sober. He explains this in his
book Evidence and Evolution published by
Cambridge University, again a mainstream
textbook on this issue, the philosophy
of biology, and he explains the tree of
life is based on a probabilistic
framework. So, like the professors were
mentioning earlier, things which look
similar, there's the assumption that
they have a common ancestor, which is
known as homology, but that assumption
of homology is something which has a uh
which has not arrival, but there's a
complexity in there. There is a
challenge in there, which is homoplasy,
that we have similarities at a
biochemical level, at a genetic level,
at a anatomical level, at a linguistic
level, at even at psychological level,
which are not due to common ancestry.
So, what he says uh in regards to this
is both of the following thoughts are
therefore naive.
Humans and chimps must share a common
ancestor because they're so similar,
and humans and mushrooms must have
arisen independently because they are so
different. There is no must within a
probabilistic framework. Now, not to
take his words out of context, he does
believe in human-chimp ancestry, and he
does believe it to be true in the
literal sense. What he's saying here is
from a scientific point of view, from a
philosopher from a philosophy of biology
point of view, what science can lead you
to is it's based on a probabilistic
framework. There are also assumptions
within the theory.
It is based upon the assumption of
gradualism,
and also that natural selection is the
main mechanism, but obviously there are
other things at play like genetic drift,
and that mutations are random. They It
was a
conference in 2016 in November in the
Royal with the Royal Society members
where they came together, the oldest and
the most prestigious society in the
world, and the central question that
they were discussing was was Darwin
right in terms of natural selection.
Now, some of the biologists were saying,
yes, he is. Some of them will say, no.
Right now, as it stands, I would say the
vast majority of biologists across the
world believe that Darwinian evolution
is the correct mechanism. The reason why
I'm highlighting these changes and these
differences is to show that that's just
the way that science actually works. And
till today, we still have biologists
like Masatoshi Nei and like Eva Jablonka
who are trying to put forth mechanisms
which they believe are alternative to
Darwin such as neo-mutationism
and neo-Lamarckism. Now, I am not
endorsing any of them.
I'm only highlighting that they exist.
This is to show that that's the way that
science actually works. Now, the view
that somebody can actually hold, as I
mentioned earlier, is the view that you
can accept Darwinian evolution to be a
working model theory paradigm. You can
accept that this particular theory is
based on a probabilistic framework which
has assumptions and there's disputes at
conceptual and a scientific level. You
can accept it as the best thing that we
have currently in science, but not to be
absolutely true. So, you don't have to
accept it theologically. Now, the late
atheist philosopher of science, David
Stove, he was an atheist and eminent
philosopher. In his book, Darwinian
Fairy Tales, he was a critic of
Darwinian evolution, but he mentioned
something which I think we can agree
with whether we agree with Darwin or we
don't.
Darwin's explanation of evolution, even
though it is still the best one
available, is not true.
So, what's he basically saying here?
Like I mentioned previously, there's two
particular ideas here. There's universal
common ancestry, which is pre-Darwinian,
but Darwin also endorsed it, and there's
the Darwinian mechanism. So, he's
referring to the Darwinian mechanism. He
thinks it's the best one available, but
it is not true in the absolute sense.
So, just to summarize, evolution does
not undermine God.
This is based on a conflation of two
types of naturalism, methodological and
philosophical naturalism. Evolution does
not undermine a deistic concept of God,
a theistic concept of God, and nor does
it undermine an Abrahamic concept of
God. This is based on the
misunderstanding that science gives
absolute truth. Science is based upon
what is known as the problem I is based
upon induction, where you take a set of
observations and you make a general
conclusion. Now, you can always have a
new
data which can challenge your previous
data. And you can always have a new
interpretation which can challenge your
previous interpretation. So, the problem
of induction is a reason why science can
never give you absolutely absolutely
certain results which never change. In
fact, there was an interesting
discussion with the philosopher Stephen
Law and Richard Dawkins, which you can
watch on YouTube, and a questioner asked
Richard Dawkins, "How can we be certain
in science when it's based upon
induction?" And he said, "Well, science
works."
The problem with that is that is
induction. So, you can't use induction
to prove induction. That's circular
reasoning. David Hume, who highlighted
the problem of induction, still took
science as a working model. We still
have the problem of induction in science
today, but it doesn't mean we throw out
the baby with the bathwater. We go where
the science leads us, but we don't have
to accept the results are absolutely
certain. Now, what I'd like to end upon
is a statement of Darwin from like the
like I mentioned earlier, the book by
Nick Spencer, Darwin and God.
Now,
Darwin had a very complex relationship
with God, and he had some very
interesting philosophical ideas about
free free and predestination and so on
and so forth.
But there's one aspect which I really
wanted you to highlight because when I
read this in that book, I just thought,
"Okay, this I I I can resonate with
Darwin here because this is the type of
awe a type of awe when a person looks
into nature. As God says in the Quran,
in the creation of the heavens and the
earth and the alternation of night and
day, there are signs for those with
intelligence. So, when someone looks
into nature, it should be something
which brings them closer to God. So,
Darwin said a statement which I really
felt close to.
"I cannot persuade myself that
electricity acts, that the tree grows,
that man aspires to the loftiest
conceptions all from blind brute force."
Everything good I have said is from God.
Every mistake is my own. Thank you very
much for listening.
Okay, ladies and gentlemen, brothers and
sisters and friends.
I learned a lot. I've been writing
notes. I learned a lot from Professor.
Learned a lot from brother Suboor. Thank
you for that.
So, now is the time for us to have a
brief discussion. I'm going to slightly
move my check my check. I don't have a
check. Um my chair, rather, backwards.
And if you could just slightly turn
here, Professor. So, I think the way to
start this off is
with a question from yourself, Professor
to Suboor, and just have a discussion.
And if there's a if there's any swords
drawn, I'm in the middle. So, I'm going
to be a silent spectator for now. So,
Professor.
Uh well, I don't I mean, I I agree with
most of what you say. I mean, I can't
think of anything specifically I don't.
Um I I I I think the ideas about Darwin
that you talk about are right. I mean, I
I I think
I think he he didn't want to be a
clergyman. I think he he was part of a
society in which the people of that
class had to look for a
I think he studied medicine in in
Edinburgh and couldn't stand the sight
of blood and when his father found out
that he wasn't going to be a doctor
anymore, he pulled his money and brought
him home and for somebody of his class,
I think being a
a a cleric was the next thing. He could
go shooting and collect beetles, which
was one of his things. Um and so he did
actually qualify, I think, as a
as a as a religion religion.
But just before he had to go back to
Shrewsbury and find a church, he managed
to get himself a birth on the Beagle and
the whole course of his life changed.
So, I mean Yeah, no, I mean I haven't
got any specific replica questions that
you need to defend against. I mean just
a discussion.
Yeah.
But so so no, I mean
I admire Darwin for being a scientist
and being somebody who
I did some work and putting together an
idea about these ideas of how change
came about and I'm quite fascinated by
the ideas that these ideas of change are
dangerous and and they influence what we
the way we interpret these things now.
Um
but I tried to trace it through and look
at people writing about this stuff and
you know, through the the 1700s and and
and and looking where did Darwin's ideas
actually come from and they
you may disagree, but
I can't see anywhere where they just
they're parts of a sequence. He seems to
have had that insight himself
building on the the stuff of others, but
he builds something new from what was
lying around and this idea that before
even Lamarck, for example,
talked about hierarchies and ladders and
things. He he made the ladder move, but
he's still got a hierarchy. Uh and I
think
I think I think so Darwin does does come
up with this this new stuff with the
tree and I like the idea that you talked
about about slavery. That was very
important to Darwin and there are some
new biographies about him where that's a
drive that idea of equality. If you look
in The Origin of Species, the only
picture is that of a tree, but it's not
a tree like we would have with the
branches all around. It's flat, and I
think that's deliberate that everything
on the end of those branches is equal
cuz at Darwin's time there were
philosophies around that there were 27
different species of human, which of
course was promulgated by the West as
part of their
dominance, imperialism, exactly, yeah.
Yeah. I mean, it's interesting you're
speaking about Darwin's belief.
His disbe- not disbelief cuz he never
became an atheist, but his doubts about
God started with the death of his
basically daughter, right? Um, and also
his son passed away 2 days before he
actually gave his paper to like the
Royal Society. And what's really
interesting is that
throughout near the end of his life he
became an agnostic because of the
problem of evil, but he was constantly
going back and forth. And what's
interesting is that Elliot Sober writes
about him that he's a methodological
naturalist. So, he said, "Okay, that's
like nature. I I can't like
I'm not going to assume that God
intervenes."
But he was never settled with the idea
that
this is all purposeless, that there's
that there's the universe is is all the
product of some sort of blind
brute force, right?
What I'm really interested in is why he
became a beacon for the sort of secular
atheistic sort of crusade against
religion and Christianity in particular.
And today, when you mention Darwin's
personal beliefs, people are very
surprised. They're like, "Okay, so he's
no longer, you know, pigeonholed as the
the head of this sort of movement." And
when when I read works like
or if you consider it works, The God
Delusion, and you just find dominant
Darwin so prominent in there. And I
think Darwin would not be happy with
that, with his name being used in in in
such a manner.
Yeah, I think that's right. I mean, I I
I think Darwin has become this cipher
that we we defend and you know, we oh
you can't say that because Darwin said
it in an almost you know religious
fervor sort of way. It's worth
remembering Darwin was wrong about a lot
of things.
The sixth edition of the origin of
species
actually Darwin was which is the last
one that Darwin contributed to. Darwin
was searching for a mechanism because
you mentioned neo-Darwinism which is the
synthesis of modern genetics with
Darwin's ideas about differential
survival. He didn't really like the
phrase natural selection because it
implied a selector whereas it's actually
life or death depending on the
the environment. And Darwin Darwin was
looking for a mechanism by which this
variation is inherited. And Lamarck's
ideas which were obviously wrong about
inheritance of acquired characteristics
the classic thing of a giraffe
stretching its neck to reach some leaves
and therefore then having an offspring
with a longer neck had been disproved
before. If you cut the tail off a mouse,
it doesn't have a baby with no tail. If
you lose your finger, you don't have
children with no fingers. This
inheritance of acquired characteristic
isn't true. But Darwin came up with an
idea and puts it's called germules and
and pan pangenesis and it's in it's in
the origin of species.
It's been disproven. Yeah and it's it
Although it's interesting I
I I used to think that and I still do
broadly. But I set my first year
students an essay called is Lamarck is
epigenetics the new Lamarckism? Yeah
because there is therefore it those of
you know about genetics that your genes
could be switched on or off because it's
cold or warm and it helps you adapt to
the environment. And people are now
finding out that some organisms their
offspring be they plants or people have
an altered those genes are still
switched off. So the environment they've
acquired a characteristic because of the
environment and then they pass that on
to their offspring and it by some
definitions that's Lamarckism. Of course
it doesn't cascade down the generations
in the same way and it doesn't change
the genetic code. Well, it's definitely
not progressive cuz that's one of the
ideas of Lamarck which we don't have
evidence for that. Things are getting
more and complexity is obviously
confusing.
But what's really interesting is when it
comes to actually
Lamarck's ideas and and you know, the
way he was ridiculed for almost 200
years. If you read Darwin, actually
flirts with the idea of acquired
characteristics.
He's finding it difficult to understand
the inheritance process. Cuz there was
no mechanism. At the time Darwin was
writing, Mendel had done his genetics.
So the genetics was there.
But nobody realized the significance
partly because Mendel was talking about
round and wrinkly peas. So you you were
either this or you were this. Whereas as
as you said in in your presentation,
we're talking about gradualism and that
you can't be a little bit more wrinkly.
So the genetics was wrong. It was
qualitative changes rather than
quantitative changes. And it wasn't
until later that we came to understand
that genes can have many effects and
many genes can have single effects. You
know, so many genes affect your height
for example. You you wouldn't be this
tall or this tall. There's a whole
gradation. And when that came, people
realized in the 20s and 30s that that
was
could be combined with that was the
mechanism. Then we get the neo-Darwinism
as you say the paradigm today.
Yeah.
What's I think very important for people
to take away as well is the distinction
between methodological and philosophical
naturalism.
Cuz that is I think central to the whole
confusion between
science undermining God, Darwinian
evolution undermining God. And this is
why I think it's very important to bring
in philosophy of science within science.
This will
uh
narrow the gap, as you know, between the
popular understanding and the academic
understanding. And also that
it'll help people to appreciate that
there's different ways of looking at the
world. It's not just, you know, let me
just put on these lenses of science,
right? There's other ways of actually
acquiring a truth. I remember a few
years ago I had a conversation with
someone um and uh I said, "Do you
believe in God?" And he said, "I believe
in science." He said it in a very
religious way. But, you know, can
science pay your bills? Can science tell
you what's right and wrong? Can science
tell you if you had if Plato existed?
You know, that's testimony. So, there's
many different roots of knowledge, and I
think this is why it's science has done
so many great things in our contemporary
society that, you know, we
we we just put all our eggs in that one
basket. So, how how do you see that sort
of playing out in the next couple of
years in the way people think? Well, I I
think I think the key point is the one
that you made when you spoke about about
um uncertainty and science and and
proof.
We can never prove anything in science
cuz we work with statistics. We work
with probability. So, you know, and
that's why scientists don't come over
very well on the radio when they're
against a politician. Um you know, and
and say, "Well, if I if if I eat this
food, will it give me cancer?" And
somebody might say, "Yes, it does
because it happened to my child." And
and the scientist will say, "Well," and
the the the interviewer will say, "Well,
does it cause cancer?" He'll say, "Well,
it might do."
And you might be one in a hundred
chance. So, they're Ah, so you can't say
it doesn't. You know, and and and I
think that that understanding of science
is as a way of dealing with uncertainty
and and trying to In a way, science is
is is a way of understanding how
uncertain we are in in in in something
that we observe.
Um and uh and and
that that's how we we organize the
world, I think. I think I think the
thing the thing the the interesting
thing we haven't really touched on the
on some of these ideas, but I mean you
mentioned a bit about morality for
example. So as an evolutionist,
I would
I would want to be able to what we call
reverse engineer any characteristic.
Okay, so you you you would say and I I
don't like using the word why in in an
evolutionary context. I try and persuade
people that evolutionists should be
saying how does something improve the
fitness of an organism? What is the
selective advantage of that? Not why
does a bird have wings? Right, but we
use it as shorthand. Why is a
philosophical question? But why does a
bird have wings? He says having
explained himself. A bird has wings
because if it has wings, it can fly away
and not be eaten and the genes for
having wings will be maintained in the
population. That's a reverse engineering
idea that sets up a hypothesis.
But we can also set up
We can reverse engineer anything. It It
doesn't mean that that thing has a
function. So you could say what's the
point of a chin? Right? Well, see that
is, but
what what is a function of a chin? Well,
it might have no function. You could
think of a function. You could probably
ask you all and you could come up with
different ideas. It sets up a But a chin
may be just the the the result of
development in the way our teeth are and
how our jaw has to be. So not
everything, as you said, has to be have
an evolutionary explanation. Yeah, I
mean we also have like the
Steven J. Gould wrote about this
extensively. We have
um these so-called maladaptations
that we have these evolutionary
byproducts.
And you know, uh the chin may be a
byproduct of this or whatever the actual
hypothesis is, but this is why it gets
very dangerous when someone takes
scientific ideas and then tries to
understand morality through them. Like
the philosopher Michael Ruse, he says
about morality that this is an illusion
created by the genes. Now,
this is actually quite dangerous
territory cuz imagine telling a
15-year-old, you know, in the in the
city Birmingham that your morality is
the illusion of your genes. I mean, that
is not going to go down too well. Yeah.
So, we we should be careful about what
science uh to to take its conclusions
and then use that as a sort of asset to
burn away theological ideas. Yeah. Cuz
you know, there's there's many different
ways of looking at the world. And I I
think it's very very important to
separate those out. And one thing that
we should, you know, try and do as as
educators, as people who want to uh
narrow the gap between the public and
the public and the academic
understanding, is get people to start
reading. Cuz we just listen all the
time. You know, you hear someone say, "I
mean, how many times have you heard
this is the gene for X."
But you'll never find a credible
scientific journal saying, "Okay, that
is the gene for, you know, bad
behavior."
So, we need to educate ourselves in that
and we need to understand that for us to
actually just to benefit from science is
not enough. If you really do want to be
grateful to science, then we should
understand how it works and also the
philosophy side of it and what the
philosophers actually say about what it
is based upon, what it can achieve and
what it can't actually achieve. I think
that's right. I mean, I think I think
it's an interesting discussion to have
about morality and and
free will as you you touched on because
our brains give us a much uh more
nuanced view of the world and
we have a view of the future, we have a
view of the self of of of of of
ourselves. We have empathy, which most
organisms don't have and it's important
for society and our previous evolution
in groups and to be successful in the
environment which we came through as a
group where we could share tasks.
Um but that that also gives us a
responsibility and
an opportunity. And if there was a gene
that meant that you didn't have empathy.
And there are there are people who who
lack empathy.
Yes, psychopaths.
And there there may well be a genetic
basis to that. It isn't a single gene.
It will be like your height, a
combination of genes. But, you know,
does that make that person evil or not
evil? Because it's not their fault. And
that that is a moral and that is also a
legal distinction. If you have a gene
that makes you do something and you and
you kill somebody, are you guilty of
murder or is it not your fault because
of of your genetics? And that that
because of where we are in our
evolutionary trajectory,
it in a way it's a curse. It's a
responsibility because you have to
develop a philosophical moral view
that takes that biology into account
because we are more complicated.
Not not only that. I mean, that's a very
that's very interesting insight. But
also that when they are scientific
ideas,
those scientific ideas have a basis.
And that basis, if you give someone that
scientific idea without giving them that
actual basis, then they can use those to
actually run away and come up with
conclusions which don't make any sense.
Like when
the
the famous selfish gene book came out,
some people misinterpreted that as a
type of
vindication vindication of of morality,
right? It it was like, okay, we
we can be selfish. Greed is good. But
anybody who understands the philosophy
side of things will understand, okay,
wait, hang on a second. That's based on
the idea of the selfish gene, which is
that the gene is the unit of selection.
And that basically that's just a model
that we have within pop population
genetics. And you cannot get a ought
from an is. You know, that's the
naturalistic fallacy. People don't get
that. People don't get what it's based
upon, what the framework is, what you
can't do, what you what you can do, you
just get the the you know, we even have
this joke in the office sometimes when
someone's doing something very selfish,
we say, "Oh, it's the selfish gene."
Right? And that's why it's it's very
very important it's very very important
to have these sort of discussions where
people from a background of science and
philosophy can come together and say,
"Okay, let's try and mitigate the
difference between the public and the
academic understanding."
The The The idea of altruism is
something that's in that was a big
problem in in the development of
evolutionary theory because you as you
say that you get your your genes through
to the next generation is the objective
if you know of evolution if I can give
it a face. Um
but we see altruistic behavior where an
organism might sacrifice itself or spend
energy that it could have spent on
itself helping somebody else to
reproduce, right? So, I mean, you know,
uh a bird um uh might It's been observed
that if birds are um
bringing up a fledglings in a nest that
another bird might help them. Uh why
would that bird help them when um uh it
could go away and have its own nest and
get its own genes through to the next
generation. So, it looks like altruistic
non-selfish behavior, but of course, the
reason is that bird is related to the
other birds and while it might not be in
a position to have a nest itself, maybe
it was too late in getting a food or
nesting site.
By helping its parents have more success
with its own eggs, it's getting more of
its own genes through to the next
generation even if they're not in the
bird itself. And I think that's
something of the selfish gene. Yeah,
just about the selfish gene though,
you say the gene is the unit of
selection. One of the things that
Dawkins gets wrong there is the gene
isn't the obvious selection because
the consequences of all the genes
working together to make a body, that's
what the environment sees with a woolly
coat or not a woolly coat, and that's
what lives or dies, not the individual
gene.
Yeah. And
this is also very important because the
selfish gene idea was W. D. Ham-
Hamilton, he
popularized it, and it's been dominating
evolutionary biology for decades. And
when E. O. Wilson's book came out, The
Social Conquest of Earth, and he
challenged that with his alternative
group selection, there was a big online
spat, which I'm I'm sure you're aware of
with the Richard Dawkins and Elliot
Sober
uh
Wilson. Wilson. So, they're having this
sort of dispute, and
I'm only sort of interested in the sort
of philosophy side of things here. So,
we're having a shift
according to some, in evolutionary
biology about the unit of selection. Is
it selfish, or is it Sorry, is it the
gene, or is it group? Now, what's
interesting is that
when they're going back and forth, so
Richard Dawkins, obviously, is very
upset. You got the selfish gene idea,
and he's he's got the Social Conquest on
of of the Earth, group selection idea.
When they're going back and forth
online, this is where a philosopher can
watch, "Okay, what's going on?" So,
there's two scientists having this sort
of debate, and the interesting thing
about the debate was it was about not
accepting a paradigm change. Cuz that's
sometimes hard for scientists to do when
they're when they're stuck within a
paradigm, they're looking at the world
through out that paradigm. Now, E. O.
Wilson got very upset cuz of
Richard Dawkins challenging him on that
particular issue. And Richard Dawkins
says, "You know, you shouldn't read his
book." And
E. O. Wilson replied back saying, "Well,
you know, if science worked in this
particular way, where, you know, it was
all about votes, right? Cuz, you know,
Dawkins got all these people saying
these are the people who actually
support me." He said, "We would still be
burning things, believing in phlogiston,
and using geocentric maps." So,
sometimes scientists, and and and
credible scientists, can get involved in
discussions because they get stuck
within a paradigm. And
Thomas Kuhn
wrote a very important book about the
scientific structure of revolutions is
that sometimes scientists can get
involved in what's known as normal
science. So, they're getting involved in
this process and they're looking at the
world through a paradigm and then
when a new paradigm comes like say
Darwinian evolution is being as a
mechanism is being challenged by
neo-Lamarckian evolution or Masatoshi
Nei's neo-mutationism or or evolution by
self
by genetic engineering by
I forgot his name. So, any of those
paradigms
it's actually according to Thomas Kuhn a
almost impossible religious experience,
right? To change from one paradigm to
another because it's been working so
well and we saw this at the beginning of
the 20th century with quantum theory
and classical mechanics, Newtonian
mechanics that some of the scientists
just did not want to accept on plate
tectonics. So, I will have to
do a paradigm shift right now and I
think it's time we have about 7 minutes
for question and answers, but
that was an amazing discussion. Nothing
around applause for that.
So, we're going to take it from the
floor.
We're going to start with questions for
Professor
and then we'll move on to questions for
Suboor or if you have questions that
apply to both, they could both answer as
well. So,
first question.
Yes, the gentleman at the back with the
hand. You, yes.
If science if science doesn't
undermine God, then why do people like
Dawkins
continue to promote
Okay, good. For the sake of the audience
who didn't hear that, if science doesn't
undermine God, why do people like me and
you refer to Dawkins and others, why do
they continue to basically push this
narrative? So, Professor
You'd have to ask Dawkins. I mean
I mean
I think I think he he's put himself in a
very radical position. Yeah. I'll come
clean, right? I'm an atheist, right? And
I I had an experience when I was very
young
in school being told by the priest, "You
have to believe this or you'll go to
hell."
And I used to lie awake at night
forcing myself to believe, and I
couldn't. And it wasn't until I was 15
that I realized, "Hold on, this I don't
have to do this."
So, for me
I don't It doesn't
it doesn't worry me.
For Dawkins, I don't know. Maybe he's
got some issue, I don't know.
I mean, he doesn't
I like him a lot and I like I don't know
the man, but I mean, I like what he
writes and I think it's it's provocative
and it stimulates debate and that's
helpful. But, I think the position and
we were talking about it earlier, I
think the position that you can know
everything for certain is not my
experience of science. It's about
dealing with uncertainty. And you could
push everything back and to naturalistic
processes all the way to the Big Bang.
If you wanted to, you could make those
arguments. But, what's before that? I
don't know.
And I think they're natural processes
that we don't understand and may never
understand.
It could be God, but I don't think it
is, but it could be. So,
I think you can't know that.
You can know it by faith, but you can't
know it by study.
Question four, Sabat.
Yes, sir. Um
So, you said that evolution does not
undermine God, but how would you
reconcile human evolution with the
creation of Adam?
Okay.
Good question. So, as I mentioned
earlier, this evolution doesn't
obviously undermine the the deistic
concept of God, the theistic concept of
God. Does it undermine the Abrahamic
concept of God? Now, evolution can mean
many different things. So, for example,
in sub-Saharan Africa,
you we have people with certain
mutations which can actually
become immune to malaria. That's the
type of evolution, if you like, human
evolution. So, what you actually
particularly talking about is human
chimpanzee ancestry. Which if you look
at the tree of life as a whole, as a
Muslim, looking at the Quran, you can't
say much about the tree of life in
general. So, the
the, you know, the whale may have had a
la
a
a mammal-like common ancestor, right?
We can't say how many origins, right?
Darwinian theory at the moment says one,
but in terms of the human chimpanzee
ancestry and the Quran,
Quranic scholars say that's not
possible. That, you know, whatever you
want to relate this species to that
species, that's not possible. So, how do
you reconcile that? Cuz that is
obviously a direct conflict in one
particular area. Now, the way I see it
is there's not a conflict. It's a
conflict if you believe science gives
you absolute certainties, cuz you have
two different ways of looking at the
world. So, one way of looking at the
world is this. Okay, I'm only going to
use science. Now, what does science
actually say about human chimpanzee
ancestry? Regardless of what you hear
on, you know, YouTube videos refuting
evolution, there's this scientist who
disagrees, this scientist who disagrees.
It's actually a complete consensus
amongst evolutionary biologists that
human chimpanzee ancestry is
is true.
From a, like I mentioned earlier, based
upon the assumption of homology. The
similarities are due to common descent.
That's there. There there's there's no
skirting that. So, how do you reconcile
that? Well, if you believe that that's
based on a probabilistic framework,
right? And that's based upon the
assumption of homology that similarities
are due to common descent. And, like I
mentioned previously, we also have the
problem of homoplasy, that we have
similarities at a biochemical, genetic,
and anatomical level, which are not due
to common ancestry. And this there's
There's of
evolutionary biologists who are worried
about this. So, you'd actually have to
do a sort of epistemic weighing, right?
So, we have science, which is based
which is giving us one particular idea,
which as Elliot Sober mentioned is based
on a probabilistic framework, which is
based upon the assumption of homology,
which is also based upon the assumption
of methodological naturalism, which is
also based upon the assumption that
natural selection is the driving force,
which is also based upon the assumption
that random mutations is the fodder for
that natural selection, and so on and so
forth.
I'm not knocking that. I'm just saying
that's just the way it is. And you have
the Quran. Okay, so which one do you go
with? Do you say, "Okay, let me throw
out the baby with the bathwater to
reject science completely." You could
just say, "Well, okay, I'm a Muslim. I
believe the Quran is true. I believe
it's personally true because of these
particular reasons. I believe it because
of this particular miracle of the Quran
or this particular prophecy of the
Prophet Muhammad, peace be upon him, or
whatever." So, you have that sort of
thing there, and you have this. So, you
can say, "You know what? I'm just going
to accept it as a working model. I'm
going to accept this as valid
a valid scientific theory, model,
paradigm. I'm going to work within that
field and contribute to that field, and
I'm going to do what God wants us to do,
which is to save lives."
What's very important is not to do what
actually happened in I'm not going to
mention the name of the university in
London, where there was an evolutionary
a a class on human evolution, and the
Muslim students walked out cuz they said
this conflicts with our faith. Now, how
are you going to live in the world if if
there's a something in science which
conflicts with your worldview, and you
decide, "Right, because this scientific
idea conflicts with my personal world
worldview, I'm just going to walk out
walk out." You're obviously not going to
get where you thought. So, the simple
thing is accept it as a working
paradigm, accept it as valid science. Do
not You don't need to get rid of your
theological beliefs. And also understand
that human chimpanzee street, to be
honest, in terms of science is a very
small discrepancy in terms of the Quran
and science. There's a much bigger
discrepancy which existed in the 50s. In
the 50s, the vast majority of
biologists, sorry, physicists, in fact,
all of them
believed in the static state model. They
believed the universe is eternal, it
always existed, and always will exist.
Even Einstein, Niels Bohr, all these
great guys, right? Now, the static state
model says the universe has no
beginning. And they obviously had
scientific uh predictive model
They had predictions which came true and
so on and so forth. Now, that
contradicts the Quran which says the
universe has a beginning.
Now, what would you do if you were a
scientist in the 50s? Reject the
science, refuse to do physics? No. You'd
You'd carry on. You'd say, "Okay, let's
let's let's see where this goes." Later
on, the Big Bang came, and that's more
in line with the Quran. 50 years from
now, the Big Bang may be replaced by the
static state model. So, what do you do?
You simply do an epistemic weighing. You
don't throw out the baby with the
bathwater. What we shouldn't do, and I
believe, and I'm going to be very frank
about this,
I don't believe Muslims should be
supporting intelligent design. I see a
lot of them do.
I don't believe we should be supporting
creation science or any of those things.
And I don't believe that those
discussions which happened like Dover in
America and so on and so forth, where
they've made the universities and the
schools into a battleground of religion
versus science, and they've even taken
this at a level where even the vice
president of
in America, Mike Pence, um you can watch
a video of him actually trying to get
rid of Darwinian evolution and replace
it with creation science. Just Just
Google it. This is a few years ago. We
don't want Muslims to get involved in
those sort of discussions. We just want
them to get involved in science, do
science, try to save lives, do what you
can, and understand that something which
you know, is made up in terms of, "Okay,
this is what we believe that happened
billions of years ago, millions of years
ago, 67 million years ago, there was a
um um uh, a split between human beings
and chimpanzees or whatever. How is that
going to stop you on a day-to-day level
to not get involved in things like
antibiotic resistance, which if we don't
solve, will actually take us back to a
new dark ages. And just a few months
ago, I had a meeting with
a prominent and one of the most
prominent
people working in this field at the
moment, Dr. Freed Khan. And he's an
evolutionary biologist who's a Muslim
who's working on this particular issue
of antibiotic resistance. He's dedicated
his life to the field of evolutionary
biology because he believes, and he said
this himself, the Quran says saving one
life is like saving all. Imagine if he
said, "Right, I'm not going to get
involved in this field because this
contradicts my belief."
You'd get nowhere.
So, we're trying to give people a
pragmatic approach where they can
contribute and they can actually
understand that it's not their role to
get involved in those theological
discussions. They can just take this
practical solution and apply in their
lives.
Okay, we have time for one final
question. It's going to be a question
for both.
Has anyone got a question that could be
applied to both the professor and
Saboor?
Is that for both, sister?
You can go for it. Go for both. That's
fine.
Oh, you have one for both? Yeah, both of
them. Okay, one for both. So, I do
apologize. Maybe you could ask him
after. Sorry.
Um, so we talked a bit about how
personal events during Darwin's life
impacted his religious opinions.
How much do you think that
uh,
maybe you talked about changing society,
how much do you think that this societal
impact that his work would have
impacted his scientific view on
on why he was questioning
That's a good question. Um,
I think there's two aspects to that. I
think firstly, his family background, I
mentioned the Lunar Society. His both
his grandfathers, Josiah Wedgwood and
Erasmus Darwin, were members of the
Lunar Society. So, he had a history of
understanding change and and what the
impact of these would be. As you said,
he trained as a cleric, so he knew the
current paradigm of what those ideas of
change would do. When he was on the
Beagle,
Captain FitzRoy, he was a
creationist who Darwin sat across the
table from and heard the consequences.
Darwin's own wife, Emma, was effectively
what we would recognize as a born-again
Christian today. So, he was exposed to
those ideas. And you could argue that,
you know, some of the reluctance Some
people do, some people disagree. The
reluctance to publish the The way that
he
exposed individual bits of the theory to
the scientific community community
without revealing the whole can
partially be explained by that
understanding. Remember, he's writing in
the time around the 1840s where people
in in in Ireland are dying of famine for
biological reasons. So, the biological
impact of that, the death of people.
There were riots in London. It's, you
know, it's that change and and this idea
and the stories that are coming from his
grandfather about the Lunar Society and
the burning of the house. So, so there's
that.
But I also think you can flip it and and
talked about the slavery and and things
and and the fact that he's thinking
about his biology and his ideas of
change and how things are
and we touched on the morality a little
bit and the way that organisms
are equal and that humans are equal. I
think he was very aware of that and to
to a certain extent that was one of his
the things that he wanted his science to
say. And I think he would have been very
disappointed with the way that there is
a There was a direct relationship with
the way that his ideas of superiority
and strength
uh used all the way through to the Nazis
and and the final solution, which can be
directly traced back through
philosophers like Nietzsche.
Uh and that would have really upset him.
So, what? It's a It's a very very
important question, and I'm sure you
know more than me on this topic, but
he was reading Thomas Malthus's book on,
you know,
uh essentially economy, how it works,
and about demand and supply, and how you
always have a lot more demand than there
is supply, and that's actually what some
historians say how he developed his
ideas of natural selection, that you
have this this huge huge amount of
demand and very little supply, and which
creates competition, and then the
majority have to basically fall by the
wayside. So, he was impacted by those
ideas, and interestingly, he was also
impacted by the general idea within
society, which was that they were
uh moving away from this type of um
Well, well,
they were they were moving towards this
this this sort of belief about the world
about progress, right? That things get
progressively better. And like Professor
Jeremy Pritchard explains in his he
explained today, but also he's got a
really important uh
uh TED Talk on this, where he explains
about um how everything is on the same
level from a from a Darwinian point of
view, that you don't have this is better
than that.
Interestingly enough, there there's some
um academics who've interpreted that he
had some of the old remnants of the
ideas of the great chain of being. He
still believed in these sort of ideas of
progress. And today, Darwinian
neo-Darwinism would totally reject the
whole idea of progress. So, he was
definitely a product of his own times.
But what I want to focus on more,
uh in just to summarize, is is on his
theology.
His theology, if you if you actually
look at some of the and there isn't
really much much work on this, but if
you look at the letters that he wrote
personally to people like Asa Gray
and and others,
he actually said, "My theology is
muddled." Because he wasn't happy with
the idea there is nothing like the like
total philosophical naturalism. He
wasn't happy with that. But then at the
same time, he just couldn't understand
why there was so much suffering. And he
he'd gone through personal suffering in
terms of his own illness and in terms of
the the death of his daughter Emma
Wedgwood, who she
Not Emma Wedgwood, Emma Darwin. And that
was his wife, wasn't it? Yeah, but his
daughter was called Darwin, yeah.
Darwin.
She's buried in Malvern if you want to
go and visit her grave. So, that really
hit him.
Uh in in fact, you know, that you could
cuz it's quite hard to re- you know,
reverse engineer what basically
happened, but the problem of evil was a
big problem for him. And I'd just like
to
just highlight there that
the problem of evil, I think, is is
something that you know, we should look
into the views of Darwin and also
consider as Muslims
that
the Quran gives us an answer about the
problem of evil in chapter 18 about God
being the wise. It's not just about, you
know, God being all powerful and all
loving. And in fact, Darwin just keeps
bringing up this issue again and again.
He just keeps saying, "I just do not
understand how God can be all loving
when all when this particular
suffering is taking place." Now,
interestingly enough, he was reading a
lot about philosophy. He was actually
reading about um
uh what's the name of that philosopher?
Uh Kant. He was reading about Kant and
reading about others and reading about
free will and free destination. And so,
you know, he was a product of his time,
definitely. And um I believe that if he
was here today, then
on the minimum, he'd want to, I believe,
read the Quran simply because he wasn't
afraid of reading other people's
worldviews
in order to sort of get a more broader
picture. And which is actually one of
the things which you can say about
Darwin was that he was a compiler and a
synthesizer because he took his ideas
from people like Charles Lyell, which
was about plate
tectonics essentially, how old the earth
is. He took ideas from
theories about economics. That's how he
got a bit of natural selection. He took
certain ideas about language and he
applied that to evolution and he made a
comparison between the evolution of
language and the evolution
of species. So he was a synthesizer and
I believe that we should we should all
in that way be open to read the works of
other people so we can actually gain
more knowledge. That's a really good
note to end.
I think it was an amazing discussion.
These are the type of discussions that
we all should be having, especially on
campus.
And I like to thank Professor Pritchard
and Suboor Ahmad for being very polite
and courteous. And
it was an amazing discussion. I've
learned a lot. Thank you very much for
your time. We're slightly over time. I
do apologize.
But I think they both deserve another
round of applause.
So have a great evening. Thank you for
coming.